[Musique]
je m'appelle steven le hyaric j'ai 36
ans et j'ai une vie absolument
passionnante
je savais que vous allez rigoler
j'ai plutôt confiance en moi et en mon
chemin me dit j'ai battu plusieurs
records dont l'a récemment sur la north
cape iv mines pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce que ça n'a pas toujours été le cas
malgré cette confiance en moi j'ai la
fraude est ici devant vous
frousse de me rater un nouveau rendez
vous avec moi même avec vous ce soir
vous êtes
presque mille parce que si c'est rempli
la hausse et ses 1000 du coup merci
bordeaux
merci à tous d'être là mais vous êtes
mis le bordel
bon il va falloir mais d un petit peu
bandeau je ferai jamais aussi bien que
les trois les trois lascars qui sont
arrivés là mais je vais vous demander
cher quand même un petit peu de bruit
pour me lancer un peu est ce que vous
êtes là bordeaux
c'est bon c'est bon
vous enflammez pas non plus hein
il faut dire aussi que l'équipe de
regards amis grave la pression
à tel point que j'en suis arrivé à
contacter tous les gens qui de près ou
de loin ont dû apprendre un texte dans
leur vie ou qui sont sur scène
régulièrement
d'amis comédiens chanteurs médecins
avocats ils m'ont tous donné mille
conseils pour apprendre cette foutue
texte mais rien n'y fait je suis même
allé jusqu'à contacter mon pote
akhenaton et qui m'a répondu par un
gentil message
en fait moi j'utilise énormément la
mémoire flash c'est à dire la mémoire
visuelle et et en fait quand j'apprends
les choses je les ai je les lis
plusieurs fois et surtout avant de
m'endormir je les lis plusieurs fois
plusieurs voire plusieurs fois et
j'essaie de les répéter sans avoir le
texte sous les yeux genre sous la douche
comme tu fais autre chose ou que par
exemple tu pédales chez sedo
merci mec quand je [ __ ] donc je [ __ ]
apparemment
et pourtant malgré tous ces conseils
tous ces experts j'ai toujours
l'impression d'avoir huit ans d'être en
pyjama et chaussons devant mon père en
train de lui réciter du 10ème
apollinaire
voilà la rga m'avait dit de commencer
par 2,3 blague j'espère que ça vous a
plu
sans transition
[Applaudissements]
sans transition en a qui font du vélo
dans la salle
qui vous vous à vous vous avez une bonne
tête de cyclistes non je rigole je vous
vois pas
ça me permet de rebondir parce que moi
ma passion c'est la bicyclette moi je
suis aventuriers professionnel et je
parcours le monde avec mon vélo je crois
qu'en fait je suis devenu aventurier
pour pouvoir vous voir vous raconter des
histoires
aujourd'hui je suis là pour vous en
raconter quelques unes d'air
j'ai envie que vous repartiez de cette
salle avec l'envié de réaliser vos rêves
vous donner comme le disait un célèbre
chanteur l' envie d'avoir envie
[Musique]
vous avez aimé aussi un
aventurier professionnel très
ostentatoire comme présentation vous ne
trouvez pas
imaginez moi à l'entrée du tibet du
népal de la tanzanie de la namibie quand
je leur dis que tu aventuriers
ils me prennent soin pour un con soit
pour un espion
j'avoue j'ai arrêté de le faire
d'ailleurs je suis désormais consultant
ça passe beaucoup mieux croyez moi et ce
qui est des consultants assala bordeaux
est ce que ça fait de la grosse facture
un peu je vous vois
je rigole je vous vois toujours pas
mon truc à moi c'est donc de traverser
des univers souvent hostile plus ou
moins lointain dangereux est presque
toujours
avec mon vélo plus concrètement et plus
sérieusement j'aimerais vous faire
partager trois expériences trois moments
de ma vie juste
trois expériences trop moment fondateur
de ma vie qui font de moi ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
la première expérience je les appelais
tu ne seras jamais coureur cycliste
ma première histoire concerne mon rêve
de gosse quand j'étais petit je voulais
devenir cycliste professionnel non pas
parce que j'adorais gagner où je voulais
être le meilleur mais pour une course en
particulier se déroulant chaque été
depuis plus d'une centaine d'années vous
l'avez
le tour de france
avant même de savoir compter je savais
donc déjà faire du vélo
j'ai commencé la compétition à six ans
au club cycliste courneuviens dans les
quartiers populaires du 93
je faisais par un
je sais que vous avez peur
ou ma jeunesse flirtait entre l'appel de
la multiplicité de conneries à faire et
mon envie de carrière cycliste après
l'intégration sport-études l'obtention
d'un baccalauréat
je décide de faire de cette passion vélo
un métier mon père me mets en garde en
me disant que ce n'en est pas un
et n'était pas le seul à avoir des
doutes sur mes capacités
un de mes éducateurs entraîneurs de l'us
créteil nous y un soir de stage j'avais
16 ans
aucun d'entre vous n'a ni le talent ni
le niveau pour devenir cycliste
professionnel ni même cycliste élite
sept ans plus tard
je remporte au tour du loir-et-cher la
plus grosse victoire de ma carrière
j'avoue ça n'avait pas la même saveur
que prévu un peu comme les plats que
vous commandez et qui ne sont pas aussi
beaucoup sur la photo je me suis rendu
compte ce jour-là que ce que j'aimais
surtout
s'était
joué à faire la course jouer à faire du
vélo mais on joue pas au vélo on joue au
golf rubis au tennis au volley au
football mais le vélo c'est pas un jeu
un peu comme la course à pied
au vélo on joue pas et j'avais décidé
comme je le fais toute ma vie d'en faire
un jeu
pour la petite histoire l'année suivante
j'arrête le vélo championnat de france
de boulogne sur mer après deux tours de
course
racée et exténuée par cette vie qui
n'était pas la mienne
cela faisait en réalité trois quatre ans
que ça me ronge et intérieurement
j'étais pas fait pour ça mais je suis
tout de même allé au bout de ce rêve de
gosse
la deuxième expérience
qui a provoqué chez moi un chemin
spirituel puissant et intense par la
suite je les appelais charles
humanitaire et de la méditation steven
mais tu sais très bien que tu n'es pas
fait pour ça
une grosse dépression suivra mon arrêt
de carrière
la petite mort du sportif comme certains
hommes ensuite
viens communicants pour des marques des
athlètes des personnalités et des
fédérations comme la fédération
française de cyclisme ou de triathlon
c'est après les jeux olympiques de rio
avec cette fédération d'ailleurs que
j'arrêterais mais point de contact avec
le haut niveau un trop-plein trop de
performance est trop d'objectifs de
résultats pour eux a été le plus gros
déclencheur de ce qui s'est passé
ensuite par mois un mois plus tard
j'arrive à katmandou au népal
pour apprendre à être apprendre tout
court à vivre au programme
humanitaire dans les bidonvilles de
katmandou j'étais un petit peu moins
barbu à l'époque
où j'apprends à donner mon énergie à des
jeunes qui n'ont rien je ne sais pas qui
des deux attendait tous de l'autre en
réalité sans doute - à vrai dire
durant
ce voyage au népal je passe également 20
jours au monastère à méditer la
méditation vipassana
une expérience aussi dur qu'exceptionnel
c'est sans doute l'une des choses les
plus difficiles que j'ai pu faire dans
ma vie
pourquoi
car le plus dur dans la vie c'est sans
doute de se retrouver face à soi-même
sans autre solution que celle d'aller
explorer l'intérieur
c'est sans doute ma plus grosse
expédition à ce jour et c'est un garçon
qui a parcouru plus d'une cinquantaine
de pays traversé des déserts des
continents et grimper des sommets à plus
de 6000 mètres avec son vélo qui vous le
dit
quelques principes de cette retraite
10 heures de méditation par jour
première session à 4h30 du matin les
baux est matinal j'ai mal quand même
dernier à 20 heures tous les soirs
interdiction de parler d'écrire de
communiquer quelqu'un d'autre que soi de
séduire de menthières de faire du sport
même marcher vite ou faire du yoga de
manger après 12h jusqu'au lendemain 6h30
après la première méditation du matin
mais
n'est ce pas ce qui est le but difficile
à obtenir qui reste le plus longtemps en
créant soir pour moi ça marche comme ça
en tous les cas pendants vipassana je me
suis revue bébés et jeunes enfants ado
je me suis vu mourir aussi comme de
nombreuses de mes aventures
pourquoi parler de la mort ici
parce que j'ai remarqué que lorsqu'on a
pleine conscience de notre mort notre
vie prend toujours une nouvelle tournure
la naissance la mort vous fait quoi
entre les deux
j'ai touché ma finitude du bout des
doigts de nombreuses reprises et en
particulier pendant cette expérience vie
personne et c'est ça qui me fait être là
devant vous aujourd'hui à tenter de vous
donner encore plus envie d'avoir envie
je n'y va pas revenir deux fois 1
me passe anna m'a pris de l'apaisement
que rien n'était grave
et que la vie n'était car permanence
j'ai fait l'expérience physique et
mentale de l'expression après la pluie
vient le beau temps
en 2018 après avoir passé ses 120 jours
au népal
je décide j'avais désormais décidé
d'aller au bout de mes rêves
je traverse l'année suivante
l'himalaya d'est en ouest en vélo par la
trace la plus haute du monde le graet
himalaya trahi
la première en vertu aventures de cette
envergure de mon existence
au programme 2000 km 90 mille mètres de
dénivelé positif
sur la distance bordeaux copenhague en
grimpant dix fois l'everest partant du
bas rhin
est temps pour moi vous partagez cette
troisième et dernière expérience
car j'ai réussi une fois dans ma vie a
touché l'expression de mon plein
potentiel
une aventure absolument bouleversante
que j'ai vécu une nouvelle fois sur deux
roues je les ai intitulé
steven le hyaric bat le record de la
course d'ultra deux ans nord skype 4000
sans le faire exprès
j'ai réussi
à utiliser à la fois mon animalité mon
intuition est mon apaisement dans un
seul et même moment vivre et accepter
ces combats intérieurs pour mieux les
maîtriser
en allant à la rencontre de mes rêves
j'ai rencontré ma pleine puissance j'ai
atteint des niveaux de conscience de
performance et de courage que je
n'aurais jamais imaginé
j'ai tout vécu en même temps
l'apaisement accompagné d'un stress
absolu le sommeil
accompagné d'un ont besoin de sommeil
cred presque chronique
une douleur physique absolument
inhumaines elle même accompagnée d'un
plaisir absolu et des larmes tous les
jours
accompagné d'un sourire presque
permanent cette expérience cette
chevauchée fantastique
a eu lieu entre le lac de garde en
italie et le cap nord en norvège au delà
du cercle polaire arctique du lac de
garde à rovereto en italie en passant
par la pologne jusqu'au cap nord j'ai
sillonné 11 pays européens à vélo
pendant dix jours je me suis déplacé en
totale autonomie avec une moyenne de 4
148 km de sel par jour vous avez mal au
cul moi aussi
une certaine rigueur quotidienne qui m'a
permis d'arriver le premier de la course
est de battre le précédent record de
près de 30 ares
[Applaudissements]
merci durant ces dix jours j'ai pratiqué
le dépassement la transmission met en
oeuvre des méditations plus ou moins
silencieuse plus ou moins mobiles j'ai
accepté l'inacceptable
je n'ai dormi en moyenne qu'une ou deux
heures par nuit
ce projet est la quintessence de ce que
je sais faire aujourd'hui sur un vélo
naviguer de jour comme de nuit quel que
soit le terrain les vents et les marées
je reste debout je tiens debout et reste
robuste et digne je ne sais toujours pas
comment j'ai fait
comme je le dis toujours ce n'est pas
moi qui fais ça c'est un autre comme ici
sur scène devant vous l'inconscient
innocent intrépide steven
en cinq ans d' aventure
steven le hyaric l'aventurier c'est un
record du monde entre paris et dakar
plusieurs records un peu partout dans le
monde dont kilimandjaro avec un vélo et
un projet 666 de plus trente mille
kilomètres à travers le monde pour le
sensibiliser sur le dérèglement
climatique
en montrant l'adaptation de l'homme les
conditions et adaptation de l'homme dans
ces univers extrêmes froid ou chaud deux
cent cinquante mille kilomètres en dix
ans des rencontres des voyages des
passions et du coeur comme je le dis
toujours je n'ai pas de talent sinon mon
courage mon coeur
est sans doute mon intuition
suivez moi
car je deviens un animal quand je suis
au pied du mur et en fait je peux vous
assurer que vous êtes tous capables de
vous réaliser de vous rencontrer de la
même manière que j'ai pu le faire mais à
travers vos propres rêves vos propres
aventures peut-être que vrai va vous
sont là en vous depuis toujours mon
objectif
c'est de vous mettre à nouveau le nez
dedans et vous montrez que vous avez
tous la possibilité de les réaliser quel
que soit votre âge statut ou profession
pour finir j'aimerais vous donner
quelques clés qui ont fait de ces idées
lubie passion rêve appelez les comme
vous voulez des réalités pour moi plutôt
cinq petites crèmes
la première est celle qui est un peu ma
marque de fabrique serait de penser
exactement comme ce mec bourré à 3
heures du matin qui paye une tournée
bien trop cher pour sa carte bancaire
en disant très fièrement devant tous ses
amis on n'a qu'une vie bordel
je sais que vous êtes là dans la salle
tous ces gars là et ses filles
la seconde comme le dira le rat comme le
dit le rappeur orelsan c'est cet essai
facile tout le monde le ferait
si c'était si facile tout le monde le
ferait j'ai eu peur de me rater mille
fois dans ma vie comme me l'a dit un ami
un ami un jour on met dix ans pour
réussir du jour au lendemain ne lâchait
donc jamais rien les amis et garder
confiance en vos rêves comme moi quand
j'ai rêvé de devenir cycliste
la troisième écrivait ses rêves annoncé
l'écrit élèves vous ne pourrez pas faire
demi-tour ensuite le plus dur c'est le
premier pas
la quatrième entourez vous de gens qui
sont dans votre énergie entourez vous de
positif d'énergie d'action et pas de
critique absolument pas constructives
par exemple aux éducateurs qui m'avait
dit que je ne serai jamais coureur
cycliste la cinquième
déconstruisent et les dessins qu'on a
fait pour vous battez vous pour vos
rêves les amis pourquoi
mais parce qu'on n'a qu'une vie bordel
croyez en vous et votre intuition vous
seul savait pour la petite anecdote le
choc le slogan d'une chaîne de
télévision qui a diffusé mon premier
documentaire
était vous partez quand essais par ça
que je conclurai ce moment avec vous les
amis vous partez quant à la réalisation
de vos rêves même les plus enfouies
alors soyez intuitif animaux passionnés
soyez fous mais n'oubliez jamais on n'a
qu'une vie bordel merci à tous
a laissé tomber jamais mais j'ai craqué
tous les genres et flore et tous les
genres tous les gens j'ai pleuré voilà
c'est ça la dimension de l'âme c'est on
a le droit de craquer mon lâche pas quoi
qu'on lâche pas tous les jours on lâche
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]